[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue pour ce
nouveau numéro du sky échos le magazine
qui vous racontent la vie des acteurs
économiques du territoire de saint
quentin en yvelines
je vous propose aujourd'hui de plongée
dans le monde de la recherche et du
développement au laboratoire national de
metronomy et d'essai à trappes
suivez-moi
[Musique]
et
le ellen est une structure spécialisée
dans les moyens de mesure comme vous
pouvez le voir autour de moi à partir de
l' expertise scientifique et technique
il travaille notamment sur l'évaluation
de l'intelligence artificielle
un projet baptisé l'eia qui sera
opérationnelle en 2022 et qui est
soutenu par le plan de relance c'est ce
que vous allez découvrir dans ce onzième
numéro du sky échos le plan de relance
continue de se déployer à saint quentin
en yvelines dans ce cadre là le député
jean noël barrot est venu rencontrer les
acteurs économiques du territoire
le laboratoire national de métrologie et
décide de trappes travaille sur une
plateforme pour évaluer l'intelligence
artificielle
un projet soutenu par l'état enfin
rencontre avec mamadou sylla cet
entrepreneur a créé la société tamba
spécialisée dans la distribution de
plats préparés africain le plan de
relance continue de se déployer à saint
quentin en yvelines deux entreprises ont
bénéficié du fonds de soutien à la
modernisation et à la diversification
pour les filières de l'automobile et de
l'aéronautique
il s'agit de generix group implantée à
guyancourt et du groupe fèves à trappes
et c'est dans ce contexte que le député
viennois jean-noël barrot travail sur le
déploiement du plan de relance dans les
territoires il s'est rendu au ski cube
pour échanger sur la situation
économique saint-quentinoise en regarder
[Musique]
hop
ce qu'on sait le saint quentin et des
yvelines que généralement c'est
qu'effectivement coexistent des
industries qui sont très très durement
éprouvée aéronautique automobile et des
industries qui vont d'une certaine
manière bénéficier de d2 l'accélération
produite par la crise je pense en
particulier au numérique et à la
cybersécurité la question c'est comment
est ce qu'on fait dialoguer ces acteurs
là faire en sorte que d'une certaine
manière la la faiblesse des uns puissent
faire la force des autres et qu'on
puisse unir nos forces sur ce territoire
des entreprises qui vont bien qu'ils
sont très peu touché on a un autre tiers
qui qui va passer entre les gouttes mais
voilà qui souffrent et puis nos tirs qui
vraiment est en difficulté
[Musique]
la question c'est comment est ce qu'on
fait dialoguer ces acteurs-là faire en
sorte que d'une certaine manière la la
faiblesse des uns puissent faire la
force des autres et qu'on puisse unir
nos forces sur ce territoire
on est des entreprises qui vont bien
qu'ils sont très peu touché on a un
autre tiers qui qui va passer entre les
gouttes mais voilà qui souffrent et puis
un autre tir qui vraiment est en
difficulté
[Musique]
ils sont pleinement engagés dans la
recherche et le développement le
laboratoire national de métrologie et
d'essai dont le site est situé à
attraper pour en parler nous sommes avec
le directeur général adjoint dû aller ne
thomas gennari bonjour bonjour
[Rires]
notre métier ol n 2 c'est de travailler
avec tout ce qui est innovation
technologique 1 ceci pour lui donner un
cadre de référence quand on a une
nouvelle technologie qui arrive ce sont
toujours les mêmes questions qui se
posent ça peut être des questions de
performance est-ce qu'on en avoir pour
son argent est ce que les performances
vont être atteinte
ça peut être aussi des questions de
robustesse 1 à ce que les performances
vont être là dans l'environnement réel
d'utilisation delà de la technologie
et puis aussi ça peut être des questions
de sécurité par se plante on a une
nouvelle technologie on peut toujours
avoir des effets qui ne sont pas
souhaitées et il est important de
pouvoir les détecter les mesures et pour
pouvoir les apprécier
c'est un organisme public rattaché au
ministère de l'économie et des finances
qui sont vos clients
alors nos clients sont à la fois des
départements des des ministères des
clients publics et puis aussi beaucoup
de clients privés qui viennent vers nous
pour venir tester leurs produits avant
de les commercialiser pour être certain
qu'ils vont donner le niveau de
performances inattendues comme je vous
le disais à l'instant voir pour sonder
d'éventuels effets qui ne serait pas
qu'ils ne seraient pas souhaité et puis
ça peut être aussi des essais qui sont
réalisés dans le cadre de démarches de
certification
la certification c'est quelque chose qui
est très utile parce que voilà on a ça
permet d'avoir une réponse simple oui
c'est bon ou non ça ne marche pas et
donc pour délivrer cette certification
il faut faire des essais et c'est là que
le hainaut intervient si on fait un
focus sur le site de trappes un duel
haineux combien de personnes ça
représente et quelles sont les missions
de ses collaborateurs donc sur le site
de trappes
on a à peu près 450 collaborateurs qui
interviennent dans les domaines de la
de l'électricité la chimie les essais en
environnement donc tout ça ça permet
d'avoir un ensemble très cohérent et qui
répond à tous les besoins de nos clients
industriels ou sinon clients québec
et là vous êtes en cours de construction
d'un projet la plateforme l'eia c'est
une plateforme qui sera dédiée à
l'évaluation de l'intelligence
artificielle un investissement d'un peu
plus de 700000 euros dont 390 mille
euros du plan de relance de l'état
oui c'est ça donc ce financement du plan
de relance on en est très heureux c'est
formidable pour nous un déjà je voudrais
remercier l'agglomération de saint
quentin en yvelines et puis aussi la
région ile-de-france qui nous ont
soutenus pour avoir ce financement dont
2 390 mille euros c'est un financement
tendues dans le cas de la
réindustrialisation des territoires
alors si on s'intéresse aux territoires
de l'évaluation de l'intelligence
artificielle
en fait on voit que on en a on en a pas
beaucoup un des gens qui font la même
chose que nous en fait on a notre
homologue aux états unis à washington le
nist on a le n 2 i à tokyo au japon
et puis il ya maintenant le
à sainté en nylon le voyez si on fait
cette carte de l'évaluation
l'intelligence artificielle maintenant
on peut dire
washington tokyo
saint-quentin-en-yvelines ça c'est très
bien et pour parler plus en détails de
ce projet on va rejoindre votre
responsable de l'évaluation de
l'intelligence artificielle guillaume a
droit
[Musique]
bonjour guillaume à brens bon alors
nicolas
[Musique]
vous êtes le responsable de l'évaluation
de l'intelligence artificielle sur le
site de trappes duel haineux alors on va
parler de la plateforme l'eia les ja
c'est le laboratoire d'évaluation de
l'intelligence artificielle
un projet sur lequel vous travaillez
actuellement ils feront quoi ça consiste
en fait en fait c'est la première
plateforme générique de mesure et
d'évaluation de l'intelligence
artificielle
son objectif est d'être en mesure de
caractériser l'environnement de
fonctionnement de ces systèmes
intelligents c'est à dire d'être capable
de dire quand est ce qu'il fonctionne
et quand est-ce qu'il ne fonctionne pas
c'est une plate forme que vous
développez actuellement qui sera lancée
au premier semestre 2022
c'est destiné à qui en fait alors cesser
une effectivement on l'a finalisera en
c'est une plateforme qui est destiné à
l'ensemble des acteurs qui développe ou
qui utilisent des technologies
d'intelligence artificielle pour les
développeurs l'objectif ça va être de
finalement effectivement caractériser
leur produit peut-être le benchmark et
faire des analyses comparatives de
performance par rapport à la concurrence
est capable d'identifier les briques
technologiques qui sont les plus
performantes
avant le lancement commercial du produit
et côté utilisateurs finaux de ces
technologies intelligentes
il ya un certain il ya un grand nombre
de produits du hac qui existent sur le
marché
et l'objectif ça va être de leur donner
des outils qui vont leur permettre de
choisir en connaissance de cause parmi
les différentes techno qui existe l'idée
c'est aussi de rassurer je suppose fois
autour de cette thématique de
l'intelligence artificielle qu'on tombe
pas sur un robot fut un jour pour
caricaturer un peu mais c'est ce à quoi
tout à fait c'est tout à fait ça
l'objectif savez de mettre à disposition
des outils d'évaluation qualification et
de certification des systèmes dia on
sait que l'intelligence artificielle
c'est un impact quasiment tous les
secteurs industriels et de notre vie
domestique avec les robots agricole les
robots d'aidé à la personne des
dispositifs médicaux intelligents les
systèmes de mobilité autonome donc il ya
un réel besoin d'acceptabilité
concernant ces systèmes dia mais c'est
aussi un outil qui va permettre aux
industriels de
de notre écosystème national et européen
d'avoir des gars qui sont plus
performantes plus fiable et du coup ça
contribuera on l'espère et c'est notre
objectif à la la relance de notre
économie de notre industrie
merci guillaume havre un responsable
d'évaluation de l'intelligence
artificielle sur le site de trappes et
donc le projet l'eia qui se développe
ici à saint quentin en yvelines
lancement de cette plateforme au premier
semestre 2022 m'a fait à l'agneau yassa
au poulet ou encore tu iap plusieurs
plats de la gastronomie africaine le
coeur de l'activité de l'entreprise
tamba implanté attrape sa spécialité la
distribution de plats préparés aux
saveurs africaines cette société
enregistre 50 % de croissance et ils
sont quatre collaborateurs engagés dans
cette aventure entrepreneuriale
c'est la séquence ma vie d'entrepreneur
avec mamadou sylla le dirigeant de tamba
[Musique]
je m'appelle mamadou sylla
j'ai 36 ans et je suis le fondateur de
tamba la première marque de plats
cuisinés aux saveurs africaines tamba
est une entreprise familiale
agroalimentaire qui est spécialisée dans
la fabrication et distribution de plats
cuisinés aux saveurs africaines en
grandes surfaces en france et nos plats
sont élaborés par le chef africaine
international qui est connu sous le nom
de chez 30e l'entreprise a été créée en
2017 et nous avons lancé les plats
cuisinés en octobre 2019 lorsque j'étais
vendeur concessionnaires automobiles
jallet
donc pendant la pause déjeuner avec mes
collègues en grandes surfaces pour pour
acheter le déjeuner j'avais du mal à
retrouver ce que je voulais c'est là que
m'est venue l'idée de retrouver l'épave
d'un moment comme je suis très attachée
à la diversité
pour moi cette proposition elle avait
vraiment du sens aujourd'hui on a la
chance d'être dans de grandes enseignes
et on a aussi notre site internet
donc sur lequel on peut commander il
twitter.com on a été vainqueur dé
snacking d'or dont qui récompense en
fait tout ce qui est smoking innovation
snacking on était sûr sur sept magasins
juste avant le confinement et à la
sortie nous confirmons donc on est passé
à 70 magasins puisqu'on avait travaillé
pendant toute cette période là c'est ce
qui nous a poussés justement aujourd'hui
à recruter
[Musique]
notre objectif à court terme c'est
d'être leader sur le marché des plats
cuisinés en france et à long terme dans
le monde
[Musique]
c'est la fin de ce numéro enregistré
depuis le ln2 trappe
merci de l'avoir suivi émission à revoir
en rifle et sur notre site internet ou
sur l'application mobile
à bientôt sur tv 78
[Musique]